hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a virtual reality headset it's a
pretty simple one obviously but that's
what it is and the idea of virtual
reality is just that it's to replace
your reality with something some new
virtual computer generated environment
and it could be some game or some
environment you walk around or some
video that's playing all around you when
you look around
but the idea is to trick your brain into
thinking that that's your new reality so
vr started with the air force actually
as part of their flight training program
and it's flight sim now obviously that's
much easier and cheaper to have new
pilots practicing stuff like fighting
maneuvers and shooting things and
ejecting and crashing all without
shooting and ejecting and crashing
actual million dollar planes so that's
where vr makes perfect sense now in 2015
companies are making these personal vr
experiences that you can just buy and
use for your own entertainment all you
have to do is just put it on your face
so they do this by taking over your site
so just like we use headphones to
completely take over a sense of sound
this headset totally takes over your
vision inside this one google cardboard
is a pair of lenses and a place to hold
your smartphone which becomes your
screen and your vr engine now there are
actually two kinds of vr headsets type 1
is the accessory that you plug your
smartphone into that becomes the screen
so something like google cardboard or
samsung's gear vr and then type 2 is the
standalone unit that does everything it
has a gyroscope and the screen and
everything built in so that would be
something like oculus rift or htc's vibe
both types of course have these lenses
that help your eyes focus on the
stereoscopic image that's right up
against your face which isn't great for
your eyes by the way but whatever and
they all have this gyroscope and
accelerometer that help track your head
movement and that's what helps put you
in your own little world so i got to
take a closer look at one of the second
type at mobile world congress this year
the new htc vive and this is something
people are getting really pumped about
it's a prototype for now and the final
version might not look exactly like this
but it's an entirely self-contained vr
headset that you can just pick up and
put on your face and be immersed of
course it's a little more complicated
than that but you have all these little
dots around it for sensors so you
actually need to set up little sensors
around you uh to track your head in 3d
space oculus rift also has some similar
looking sensors for the same reason it's
tracking your head so on one hand that's
going to be awesome for immersion the
more accurate these sensors can be the
more closely it'll mirror your head
movement so since you're in 3d space you
can literally move your head forward and
peek around a corner which is pretty
awesome but on the downside that does
require having a little bit more space
to actually set up your vr experience
which sounds kind of like a pain
and also the thing people forget is you
also need a set of cables to connect
this vr headset to your computer so
plenty of people did demos without
plugging it in but you're not exactly
untethered when you're really using it
now that first type of vr headset that
uses your phone as the vr engine and the
screen is actually a little bit more
simple your phone already has a
gyroscope and an accelerometer built in
so all of your movements around that 3d
world will come from that but these
don't have the advantage of sculpting
the optimal vr experience i mean it's
kind of like an accessory and it's a
little bit weird to like clip your
smartphone into
some crazy basically oversized case and
then strap it on your head but
the experience can often be almost as
good as one of the dedicated headsets at
least to a vr noob like me but look
making a vr headset right now at least a
good one is really hard there are so
many things you have to consider the the
pixels per inch of the display since
it's right up against your face and it's
magnified and then there's the field of
view since you want it to be as
immersive as possible and the pixels per
degree since everything's magnified and
so close to your face
there is good hope though i've never
seen an industry go so fast from zero
like almost nothing to five or six major
players so fast you've got oculus rift
you have samsung gear vr you have google
cardboard's been out for a year htc vive
is on its way it's coming sony project
morpheus is also coming i would actually
even say that microsoft hololens
although that headset from microsoft
that everyone's talking about the
experience of is not virtual reality
that's actually augmented reality so
virtual reality and augmented reality
are two slightly different things so to
clarify virtual reality is replacing
your entire reality so you're immersed
in this new world with nothing left from
the real world
augmented reality is just that it's
augmenting your reality a little bit
it's adding some things and combining it
with the real world and oftentimes
that'll be in the form of an overlay or
seeing something on top of a real world
object google glass also does the same
thing so you can have useful information
sort of in the corner of your vision not
totally virtual reality but some neat
augmented reality tricks but what really
separates vr and what makes it so
impressive
is the immersion factor the fact that
you're totally in this world so just
like with headphones on when you can't
really hear anything else other than the
music you're listening to with a vr
headset you're essentially blindfolded
and put into this entire new world with
whatever the artist makes
virtual reality content will take off
when there is a lot of virtual reality
stuff to look at like 3d tv would have
only made it if people everywhere
started making 3d videos now obviously
that didn't happen and there's a risk
that virtual reality might not ever
happen too because of that but i think
there's at least something special here
that 3d tv might not have had i think
the first time someone sees a 3d tv that
works really well the reaction might be
oh wow
but the first time someone sees like
oculus rift or gets a really good
virtual reality demo they're like
wow this is impressive that's what makes
it so cool so uh yeah the next time
you're considering whether or not
virtual reality will become a thing or
not think about what would you do with
it
so thanks for watching
i'll talk to you guys the next one
peace